uh next question for you is regarding
the prophetic tradition of the Prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam
there is aab on gold and silver um could
you explain that and is it the same in
both cases gold and silver as far as
nisab for gold is concerned the nisab
for gold is 85 gram of gold
or 7 and 1 half TOA gold that is one TOA
of gold is equal to 11.33 G
approximately so gold isal 85 g of gold
so if it reaches that nisab level or
above this and if it stayed with you for
one year then zakat is compulsory based
on the Hadith of wasallam which is
mentioned in Sun Abu
daud in the book of zakat volume number
two Hadith number 1568 where the Beloved
wasallam said
that zakat
is on you that is on gold if it reaches
20 dinar zakat is not there if it's less
than if it is then zakat is f and one
din is equal to one mcal one mcal is 4
and a qu G so 20 by 4 and a quar comes
to 85 g of gold so the nisab level for
gold is 85 g of gold and again it should
be with you for one
year and the
percentage of zakat is mentioned in the
Hadith
ofn ma in the book of zakat Hadith
number
1791 it's mentioned
that pleas with her she says that the
prophet used to take half din for every
20 dinar and one dinar for every 40
dinar that means 140th of the portion or
in percentage by 2 and half% so whatever
gold you have with you that 85 g of gold
or above you have to give 2.5% of that
gold if it's with you for one
year in
zakat as far as the nisab for silver is
concerned it is 595 gr of silver
or 52 and a half
Tas of silver and the percentage of
zakat is the same it is 2 and
half% a beloved Prophet wasallam said
inkari Vol number two in the book of
zakat Hadith number
1447 that zakat is due on five Oka of
silver one Oka is equal to 40
Dam so 5al 200 Dam and
200 dam is equal to 595 G or 5 and half
TOA so if the silver reaches the nisab
level the nisab is 5.95 g of gold or 52
and a half TOA and the Beloved Prophet
said in Abu da number two in the book of
zakat number 1567
that pay
140th that means give 140th portion in
zakat so even for silver the percentage
is 2 and a
half% so for gold and silver the zakat
percentage half% the nisab Loy for gold
is 85 g of gold or 7 half TOA and for
silver the nisab is 595 G of silver or
52 and half TOA of silver thank you Dr
Zaki